Hello Mr. Krachten.
Hello Mr. Hasselhoff.
Mein Name ist Lubosz.
Und ich habe eine Frage an Sie.
Mr. Hasselhoff, Sie sind ein sehr
beliebter Mann hier in Deutschland.
Die Menschen mögen Sie.
Die Menschen lieben Ihre Filme und Musik.
Warum machen Sie es also
nicht wie Arnold Schwarzenegger?
Dem mutigen Mann aus Österreich der
in die Vereinigten Staaten ging und Gouverneur wurde.
Warum kommen Sie nicht hierher nach Deutschland,
machen ein Paar gravierende Geschäfte,
und werden vielleicht "BundesChancellor",
oder sogar State Secretary.
Wir könnten hier bald einen neuen brauchen.
Rufen Sie nur an!
Ich glaube das ist eine sehr gute Idee.
Ich glaube ich komme nach Deutschland und werde
The Hoffinator!!!
Ich werde The Hoffinator, und
ich werde The Bürgermeister sein.
Ich werde der Minister of Motivation sein.
Weil Sie mich motiviert haben
muss ich nun GANZ Deutschland motivieren.